les enfants sont là le mercredi c'est le
jour où le nourrit les animaux du parc
mais tout d'abord remontons le temps
1964 les 35 hectares appartenant à la
ville sont consacrés à la création d'un
parc paysager 1967 lors des premières
floralies internationales
le parc devient par cofor depuis il se
transforme continuellement pour nous
rendre curieux de botanique en essayer
de créer le parc avec différents jardins
toujours dans une dans un souci de
pédagogie on montre aux enfants et aux
grands aussi d'ailleurs si on a qui ne
savent pas on leur montre comment
évoluent les plantes comment on suit les
saisons comment elle n'est comment elle
vit comment elle meurt donc on a des
jardin de rocaille où on peut voir des
plantes alpines des plantes aquatiques
on a toute la prairie spontanée on a
également les iris avec leur dégradé
chromatique les dahlias avec toutes ces
magnifiques couleurs
on a également les zones tropicales on a
beaucoup d'endroits beaucoup de jeux à
découvrir au parc floral qui changent
suivant les saisons
les treize jardiniers sont réunis pour
planter les dernières fleurs d'automne
au rythme des saisons les floraisons se
succèdent
d'abord dans les sous bois puis dans les
jardins ou le long des allées un
renouvellement qui se prépare dès
l'hiver il est moins ouvert l'hiver on
les jardinets au moins travail mais
on a autant de travail l'hiver que l'été
car on profite justement de l'hiver pour
remettre le parc en l'état on fait donc
puisque les plantations ont fait
également toutes les tailles d'arbustes
d'arbres tout ce qui rend massage de
feuilles et tous les entretiens qu on
n'a pas pu le faire pendant la haute
saison l'ont fait pendant l'hiver le
parc se divise en deux parties le coteau
de sologne et la plaine du val de loire
le coteau et le domaine d'une forêt semi
naturels de charme et de chênes
contrastée par 2 min paysage venus
d'ailleurs
la plaine traversée par le loiret et sa
source résurgence souterraines de la
loire est divisé en espace changeant au
fil des saisons
parc animalier serre aux papillons
potager roseraie jardin exotique
les collections de fleurs
tous
là
ton
on encourage les gens à s'égarer en fait
à se perdre dans le parc a pas toujours
utilisé les sentiers balisés au
contraire pour découvrir les petits
endroits on n'a pas l'habitude d'aller
justement c'est assez agréable pour ça
on accueille effectivement beaucoup
d'enfants de centre aéré des enfants
avec leurs parents leurs grands parents
beaucoup d'enfants de centres de loisirs
ou d'école et on leur montre la nature
comment allait évoluer également la
faune dernières couleurs vives pour la
dernière collection de l'année le dahlia
c'est une fleur qui est magnifique car
elle est l'alliée aussi bien à tous les
coloris qu'on peut trouver à part le
bleu et toutes les formes de fleurs que
l'on peut trouver aussi bien grandes
fleurs du fleur des petites boules donc
l'avantagé de ces plantes c'est qu'en
fin de saison par le public vient au
parc ou encore une magnifique collection
quand on est quand on est un immense
massif ou quand on est en train de
travailler des gens ont toujours un peu
de questions parce qu'ils ont ils en
ciel plantes chez eux ils savent pas
comment faire pour après ba reproduire
ce qu'on fait ici au parc chez eux
pour une heure une journée pour
contempler flâner jouer ou apprendre la
botanique
le parc floral se prête au jeu en
réinventant chaque année une façon
d'envisager le paysage